[موسيقى]
بملابس عربية عندما رفع كأسه
ليس لي شرف إنه لشرف
يمكن ان يحصلوا
ينقل الثقافة ضدنا
ضد x أفضل رقم في العالم
كانت الحقيقة لا تشوبها شائبة
بقيت 10 أشياء جيدة لي
بالنسبة لي من أصل 10 Excel لديك مشاكل في ذلك
عندما كان ميسي يرتدي ملابس عربية
رفعت الزجاج أمس سعادة تامة
لقد فهمت أنه كان شرفًا لاحقًا
لقد أجريت بحثًا لم أكن أعرفه في البداية و
كان الأمر غريبًا لأنني كنت أمتلك شيئًا ما على عاتقي
لم أكن أعرف ما كان عليه ولكن لاحقًا متى
اكتشفت الأمر وقالوا لي إنه عباءة
التي مثلت دعنا نقول الملوك هناك
لقد فهمت وأخذت في الاعتبار أن
يقام العالم في مكان ما عليك
لديهم ثقافة المكان الذي
جعل كأس العالم هذا هو الشيء المهم
لأننا إذا كنا في قطر فإننا نحترمها
التقاليد القطرية لأن ذلك هو
حتى لو كنا في الأرجنتين حسنا
سيكون جوري مشوي لكننا في قطر
لذلك أنا أقدر أن لديهم
منح مثل هذا بالنسبة لي يبدو شرفًا
لاتوجد مشكلة الامر بخير
إنه رائع ، مرحباً ، كيف حالك إنه مثالي
أن لديهم
مزينة بهذا واحد مع ذلك سترة لذلك
يوم مهم في قطر غير صحيح
لأنه كان من هذا القبيل كان يوم قطر على
الوقت وبعد ذلك هو الكمال وماذا
اعتبر ملك المكان و
جيد للجميع
كرة القدم وميسي هو الأفضل هو
رقم واحد جاهز لا توجد كلمات
[موسيقى]